From beloved arthouse classics
to forgettable horror revivals,
these franchises couldn't wait a full twelve
months before releasing their next installments.
There are sticklers out there who will tell
you that The Man with No Name — the strong,
quiet anti-hero played by Clint Eastwood
in Sergio Leone's trilogy of landmark
Westerns — does have a name. In fact, he
has three names. In 1964's "A Fistful of
Dollars" — wherein our man pits the rival
factions of a small frontier town against
one another — his name is Joe. In 1965's "For a
Few Dollars More," however, his name is Monco,
and he's a bounty hunter who joins forces with a
rival to take down a Mexican bank robber. Finally,
in the 1966 semi-prequel "The Good, the
Bad, and the Ugly," he is called Blondie
as he races against a ruthless mercenary and a
wily bandit to find a stash of Confederate gold.
You might have noticed that Eastwood isn't
really the same character in each of these films,
nor were they released in the same
year. After the spaghetti Westerns
made waves in Italy and across Europe,
United Artists released them all in
1967 — the first two in January and
May, and "The Good, the Bad, and the
Ugly" in December. The artwork for the American
releases emphasized that the films were all of a
piece, and introduced the moniker of "The Man
with No Name" in an attempt to bind the films
more closely together. The marketing campaign
worked like gangbusters — and all these years
later, the three films are still packaged
together as "The Man with No Name" trilogy.
The circumstances that led to both Roger Moore
and Sean Connery playing James Bond in 1983
are complicated and go back several decades
earlier. In the '50s, Bond author Ian Fleming
collaborated with writer Kevin McClory on an
unused 007 film script that eventually became
the novel "Thunderball." Later, in 1961, McClory
sued Fleming and eventually was awarded a story
credit on the novel's 1965 film adaptation, as
well as ownership of certain story elements — most
notably, the terrorist organization SPECTRE
and its cat-loving leader Ernst Blofeld.
McClory spent more than a decade in various
legal battles with United Artists in order to
make his own film, and in 1983 he finally got
his chance. "Never Say Never Again" — produced
for Warner Bros. — is essentially a remake of
"Thunderball," with SPECTRE once again holding
the world hostage with a pair of nuclear warheads.
Its ace in the hole, of course, is Sean Connery,
returning to the role he made famous for the
first time since 1971's "Diamonds Are Forever."
"I hope we're gonna have some
gratuitous sex and violence."
"I certainly hope so too."
The film also boasts solid action scenes from
director Irvin Kershner and a great performance
from Barbara Carrera as the scenery-chewing
femme fatale Fatima Blush. Meanwhile,
the official Bond franchise kept chugging
along in the same year with the very silly
"Octopussy," which has 007 — played by Roger Moore
in his sixth appearance — foiling a rogue Soviet
general and an exiled Afghan prince with the help
of some beautiful circus-trained jewel thieves.
In 1984, the schlockmeisters at Troma
Entertainment scored a genuine hit with
the superhero parody "The Toxic Avenger," in which
wimpy janitor Melvin Junko is dumped into a vat of
toxic waste and emerges as a monster who dedicates
himself to fighting crime. Five years later,
"the first superhero from New Jersey" returned
in "The Toxic Avenger Part II." In the sequel,
Toxie travels to Japan to find his
long-lost father, leaving Tromaville
helpless to the machinations of the supervillain
corporation Apocalypse Incorporated. Thankfully,
though, he comes back to save the day. After all…
"If Tromaville was destroyed, there would
never be a 'Toxic Avenger Part III!'"
The original cut of "Part II" reportedly ran
close to four hours, so Troma mastermind Lloyd
Kaufman did the only sensible thing and made
two movies out of it. "Part III" — subtitled
"The Last Temptation of Toxie" — picks
up at the second half of the story.
When Toxie returns from Japan and runs Apocalypse,
Inc. out of town, he finds that he did his job
too well, as there are no more bad guys left
in Tromaville to defeat. In need of a job to
pay for a medical operation that could restore
his blind girlfriend's sight, Toxie does the
unthinkable and takes a job with Apocalypse,
Inc. But will success and the trappings of
yuppie life spoil our lumpy protector? And is
the chairman of the evil corporation even more
evil than previously advertised? The "Toxic
Avenger" saga has to be seen to be believed.
Polish filmmaker Krzysztof Kieślowski's
"Three Colours" trilogy consists of
three films that have mostly unrelated
characters and plots, but are united in
theme and intended as a singular experience.
After all, when U.S. critics were preparing
their best-of lists for 1994, the films
took up one ranking spot instead of three.
The title of each installment refers to
the three colors of the French flag and
the ideals they represent: blue
for liberty, white for equality,
and red for fraternity. "Blue" arrived in
late 1993, starring Juliette Binoche as a
wife and mother who is cruelly "liberated" by the
death of her husband and young child. Struck numb
by grief, she strikes up several unexpected
connections as she struggles to move forward.
"White" and "Red" were both released in 1994. The
former concerns an unhappy man who, after getting
a divorce from his wife, smuggles himself back
home to Poland inside a large suitcase. Meanwhile,
"Red" follows a model living in Geneva
who connects with a retired judge after
she accidentally hits his dog with her
car. Each film has the lean efficiency
and finely tuned irony of a good short story,
and none of them quite turn out as expected.
No other single film did more to define sci-fi
in the 21st century than the Wachowskis' 1999 hit
"The Matrix." The dystopian-martial arts-superhero
mashup coined a whole new cinematic language,
and its impact can still be seen in its
aesthetics, special effects technology,
and — perhaps unfortunately — in real life
today. A sequel was all but guaranteed,
but the task of living up to fans' massive
expectations was daunting. Four years after
Neo flew through the air at the end of the first
film, the Wachowskis returned with not one sequel,
but two: "The Matrix Reloaded" in May 2003
and "The Matrix Revolutions" six months later.
The films promised everything a sequel should
have — like bigger and better action set pieces
and more of the characters we loved from the
first film — along with a few answers to the
many questions posed by its increasingly
convoluted mythology. But while the sequels
delivered the goods when it came to action — the
highway chase in "Reloaded" remains an all-timer
decades later — it fared less well when trying
to untangle its own dorm-room philosophical
inquiries. "Revolutions" was largely seen
as a disappointing capper to the trilogy,
and when Lana Wachowski returned 18
years later to helm the reboot "The
Matrix Resurrections," she crafted a proper
ending as much as she did a new beginning.
"That's the thing about stories…
they never really end, do they?"
The 2000 Canadian horror flick "Ginger Snaps"
took on the werewolf genre through the lens of
female adolescence and puberty, as spooky teen
sisters Ginger and Brigitte work to control
Ginger's violent monthly urges after she is bitten
by a werewolf. The 2004 sequel, "Ginger Snaps 2:
Unleashed" takes a page from "A Nightmare on Elm
Street Part 3" as Brigitte, now infected herself,
tries to resist her transformations while
staying in a rehab facility for teens. Ginger
returns from beyond the grave, appearing
to Brigitte in visions with ghostly advice.
Filmed simultaneously with "Unleashed," the
prequel "Ginger Snaps Back: The Beginning"
offers a frontier variation on the series. Stars
Katharine Isabelle and Emily Perkins return not
as the Ginger and Brigitte we know and love from
the first two films, but as their 19th-century
ancestors — also named Ginger and Brigitte — who
find themselves orphaned and lost in the Canadian
wilderness. Where werewolves are a symbol for
menstruation in the first film and addiction in
the second, "Ginger Snaps Back" uses the genre's
sturdy framework to examine Canada's history of
colonialism and indigenous extermination. Even
though the sequels weren't particularly beloved,
they weren't particularly hated either — and
they both make for entertaining viewing nowadays.
The tongue-in-decaying-cheek "Return of the
Living Dead" series ran for three bloody,
campy entries from 1985 to 1993. But just like
a corpse exposed to the military-grade poison
gas Trioxin, the series rose from the
grave more than a decade later. In 2005,
two brand new "Return of the Living Dead"
sequels were unleashed upon the world,
putting a new generation of teens in the
path of shambling corpses hungry for brains.
"Necropolis" — the first of the new sequels —
follows a group of high school students whose
friend is kidnapped by a nefarious corporation
doing research on reanimated bodies. Actor and
frequent documentary narrator Peter Coyote guest
stars as the doctor in charge of the experiments,
and he appears once again in the
follow-up "Rave to the Grave."
"What is all this for?"
"Isn't it obvious?
World domination! What's everything
ultimately for? Heh heh."
Taking place a year after the zombie outbreak
that ended "Necropolis," "Rave to the Grave"
follows the surviving high schoolers —
now in college — as a stray canister of
Trioxin gets synthesized into a party drug
that starts turning ravers into zombies.
Beyond using Trioxin as the source of
the zombie scourge, the films — which
wound up going straight to the Syfy Channel
— bear little resemblance to the first three,
lacking their punk rock sensibility
and love for gooey, goopy monsters.
Kiyoshi Kurosawa's 2001 horror-tragedy "Pulse"
was part of a wave of internationally acclaimed
Japanese spine-tinglers released at the turn
of the millennium. Naturally, its inevitable
American remake — directed by Jim Sonzero and
co-written by Wes Craven — arrived in theaters
in 2006. It stars Kristen Bell as a university
student who discovers that her boyfriend's death
was caused by a supernatural computer virus that
allows the dead to contact the living through the
internet. Like the Japanese original, the
remake has the courage of its convictions,
ending on a note of defeat as the virus takes
hold and the spirits of the dead invade the earth.
The two "Pulse" sequels, both released in 2008,
take place in a world overrun with ghosts where
the living now exist as refugees in their own
homes. "Pulse 2: Afterlife," which features a
man trying to protect his daughter from the ghost
of his vengeful ex-wife, is nearly unwatchable —
every scene appears to have been filmed in
front of a green screen. "Pulse 3" doesn't
fare much better visually or narratively: this
post-apocalyptic take on the material features
a college student navigating the new world and a
young woman who somehow discovers the world's last
working laptop. You should probably click away
from these sequels if you ever run into them.
"I want to turn it off, but… I can't."
Swedish crime writer Stieg Larsson's posthumously
released "Millennium" trilogy became a global
sensation when the first novel, "The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo," was published in English in 2008.
A feature film adaptation from Swedish production
company Yellow Bird followed in early 2009,
along with adaptations of the other two novels in
the series, "The Girl Who Played with Fire" and
"The Girl Who Kicked the Hornets' Nest," later in
the year. The complete trilogy was given a limited
theatrical run in the United States in 2010 by the
distribution arm of Chicago's Music Box Theater.
Starring Noomi Rapace as hacker Lisbeth
Salander and Michael Nyqvist as intrepid
journalist Mikael Blomkvist, the films are a
pitch-black journey into the sins of Sweden's
past. For international audiences, it's also
possibly their first taste of the uniquely dark,
sexy, and disturbing genre of Scandinavian crime
fiction. Director Niels Arden Oplev doesn’t shy
away from the sexual violence that is endemic
to Larsson's work — the original Swedish title
of "The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo" translates
to "Men Who Hate Women," after all. While the
sequels may not have the same visceral thrill as
the first film, all three were released together
to paint a bleak portrait of a culture that has
yet to reckon with the rottenness at its core.